what's up chess friends how are you guys
doing hope everything is fine this is
spanish grandmaster peppercoinker and i
welcome you to
games of the week lecture
so as you guys know the us championship
is happening
these days with ulta guns lane carolina
camura
jefferson wesley saw and uh
company and after
eight rounds wesley saw and jeffrey
shawn were
leaving the tournament with seven out of
eight points
fantastic performance and therefore this
ninth round was uh very important
because the
well the one who who wins takes the lead
right
so let's try to analyze what happened in
this uh
fantastic game between wesley saw and
jeffy shawn
so i see already a lot of people in the
chats you guys know i'm gonna ask you a
lot of questions this is gonna be worse
than a
university exam so please feel free to
make just
some sorry your suggestions all the time
i'll be more than happy to answer all of
your questions
all right so let's analyze the game e4
from wesley so by the way the tournament
hasn't finished yet so still some runs
ago you can
follow with commentary in the channel c5
sicilian by jefferson not f3
knight c6 there are many different
sicilians right you can go for the
accelerated dragon
you can go for e6 here aiming to go for
the paulson or the taiman off right
you're gonna even play
not f6 but okay knight c6 from
jefferson now uh you can
open with d4 entering in the open
sicilian or you can
play different stuff here to stop the
shfeshnikov
for example fabiano caruana used to play
a lot the rosalina
against uh magnus carlsen just to stop
uh
to avoid entering in the especially of
sicilian right so bishop bifa the
rosaliemo
this is a more positional approach you
you can also play
knight c3 this is another
anti-spashnikov but then in this case
black can try to play
bishop s or e5 right
okay guys so d4 open sicilian
uh from wesley saw c takes e4 knight
takes d4
and knight f6 attacking the pawn on e4
white goes knight c3 and here again
different options for black g efficient
goes for the
specinic of pelican defense but here you
can try g6 this is the classical
sicilian
you can go g6 again going for the
accelerated dragon
even e6 is a move at this position where
after knight d to b5 this could even
transpose to the especially off
if black plays d6 because now after
bishop f4
black is forced to play e5 bishop g5 and
then we are back in the spashnikov
or black can play for example bishop b4
and then this is
a whole different story right a3 bishop
takes c3
knight takes e3 and d5 and this is a
whole different story
but okay the especially of one of the
most aggressive
openings for black against e4
well uh you could say at home come on
pepe this e5 i don't know i don't
understand d5
becomes a very weak square that's
completely right but then
as you're gonna see this knight is going
to be misplaced
in the in the middle game in many
occasions this knight
ends on a3 which is a pretty bad square
for the knight right
and that's why
this this move e5 is fully justified
yeah
because uh you gain some tempi in terms
of development right
it's true that d5 is going to be weak
for the rest of the game and
basically white is going to play uh
it's going to try to use that square but
as i told you
knight is going to be misplaced and then
you gain some some
some temp in terms of development all
right so here
knight b5 why knight b5 well you got
knight b3 many people
go for this when they don't know
openings now bishop b4 is very strong
because now d5 is coming in in many
in many occasions for example after
bishop d3 you can go even bishop takes
c3 b takes c3 and then short castle
followed by d6
or even you can play d5 in one in one
move and then black is perfectly fine so
this is way everybody goes here knight d
to b5
and now black is basically forced
to go d6 in this position because you
start with a6 this knight of course is
not going to a3
but instead it's just going to d6 and
it's
forcing black to take on d6 and then
this gives off sorry gives us the bishop
pair and
this is considered to be a bit better
for white right
too many variations chess is so hard i
know crazy christoph
i agree with you you're not being placed
i've been playing sorry
chess for 25 years already and then i i
i know nothing you know
it's crazy this game yeah
okay so d6 the idea is to cover that
square
and then a6 is going to be next move
so here there are two main options uh
two main lines the first one is bishop
g5 which is
what wesley saw played in this position
but then there is another
main move in this position do you know
this move guys
it was played basically in every game
against
magnus cousin in the world championship
match
fabiano caruana used this weapon
and this move is
do you think carol will be able to beat
wesley so today i mean he's so able to
beat everyone yeah he's not having his
best tournament but of course in one
game he can crush
wesley song yeah knight d5
that's the other move and now this is
forcing black to take on d5
and now black is taking on d5 with the
pawn and there are
two moves here so main line is knight b8
there's another option with knight e7
and now after c4
i want to ask you what would you play in
this position it's a tricky position
it's a very tricky position and then i
won so many games
when i was a beginner using this
line against especially because there is
an important trick here what would you
play here
with the black pieces no 95
95 is not possible here
bishop d7 bishop d7 this just blunders
mating one don't go for this
now f5 f5 is not a very good move
come on guys give me your candidate
boops i mean
there is an annoying knight on b5
there is an annoying knight on b5 so do
you want to kick this knight from b5
yeah a6 antonio insane a6
simeon is saying a6 you you all guys
fell for the truck
a6 is just losing so the main moves here
are knight f5 or knight g6 both have
been employed by magnus carlsen in the
world championship against faviano
caruana
a6 is a well-known trap
because now queen a4 just wins
you cannot take on b5 because rook and
is hanging and of course your threat is
just to go
knight g6 mate or knight c7 mate
for example after queen d7 days knights
d6 or even knight c7 both
both wins and then bishop d7 again same
trick knight g6
so be careful because probably a6 is the
most natural mode just play a6 thinking
okay my opponent has to go back to c3
but actually he loses because of queen
e4
so that's why you have to play let's say
knight f5 and now queen a4 is not so
strong because of bishop d7
and the key is that this g6 pawn is
actually well protected
protected sorry from the bishop on f8
and the knight on f5
and then of course you wanna continue
with a6 this is still theory
white can go queen before but then this
is uh this is a whole different story
okay
very good and
okay this is another line but wesley saw
went for
bishop g5 i mean this is a
this is a very natural idea right we
want to use the d5 square with a knight
so we just eliminate
one defender of that square which is the
knight on f6
here black plays a6 finally kicking this
knight
uh that has to god is first to go to a3
and this is why i was telling you the
knight is misplaced it
it's completely out of the game right
now
black can play here b5 or bishop e6 b5
is the most natural move threatening
this fork and b4
after bishop e6 now we are on time
to bring this knight back to the action
because now uh
black didn't play b5 so we just played
knight c4 and then this knight is
going to e3 controlling d5 very strongly
okay um who is your bet in the
candidates nepal or ding or fabi well
thing didn't start
very good you know being i think i i
would say ding hasn't got
decent options to qualify for the world
championship match but nepo bachelorette
even favi yeah favi is only one point
behind but as you guys know the
candidates was cancelled again
till spring 2021 so we'll see what
happens yeah
it's very tough to plan any events uh
right now i'm gonna play a tournament
tomorrow in spain it's a rapid
tournament and i know hundred percent
that it will happen yeah you never know
because the government the government
says you know
we close this region we close that
region and then
you cannot uh play more than 10 people
in one room so
stuff like this and then basically it's
really tough to
to plan anything these days right with
with the pandemic zoom
we'll see what happens so p5 and here
there are
two main lines of course b4 is that
right so we're gonna move this this
knight from c3 sooner or later yeah
so knight d5 from wesley saw the other
option is bishop takes f6
g takes f6 of course because now after
queen f6
now the knight comes with a tempo to d5
queen d8 and now
there are interesting moves here for
example c4 but even this sacrifices
is very good bishop takes v5 and knight
takes v5
and white is actually much better in
this position
so b sub f6 gtx f6 and then
knight d5 i recommend you the move g3
actually
i gave a lecture on this the other day
in the twitch channel of the saint louis
chess club
so i won so many games with this g3 line
i'm guarantee you you i mean it will
surprise your opponents i played this
line with g3
uh against people who played this
vesnika for 20 years and then they
didn't know about this line and there
are so many tricks
so you have an hour just go to the twit
channel and check this line
i also have a video series about this in
chess 24
so there's plenty of material all right
but in this game
after b5 knight d5 of course it's a very
natural move for now bishop e7
here how would you take on f6 with the
bishop
or the knight so you play bishop f6
or knight f6 i mean it's clear that now
black is just threatening to take on d5
so we have to exchange that piece on f6
right
[Music]
that knight's working on a hell of a
tour it started on g1
it's now on on a3
yeah bishop f6 this is the whole idea we
want to use the d5 square now we
if we do all this and then we take on f6
with the knight
this is just a joke yeah gtx f6 and then
let's say bishop b3 and now black is
just striking in the center with f5
typical ideas in this questioning of
yeah
so let's take with the bishop and then
use the weak square d5
all right very good very good sorry
bishop f6
and here c3 by wesley so we said that
this bit this knight is
terribly placed on a3 so we want to
bring this knight to the action
and one interesting square is c2 from c2
we can go to e3 and then
reinforce the control on the d5 square
also we are covering f5 which is
another interesting square because the
you know black's contour play
in many cases is related with a break on
f5 right
so c3 other option here is to play the
move c4
basically it has the same idea just to
bring the knight to c2 so c3 from wesley
saw
and now bishop g5 from jefferson the
bishop on g5
is well placed now the knight is not
hitting that bishop anymore and then in
the future
you can continue with short castle and
then at some point five there are
different interesting ideas for blocking
these positions
so many cases you want to bring this
knight to e7 as well
to eliminate this strong knight on d5
and then at some point you can also play
something like g6 to play
f5 and then recapture with with the g
pawn on f5 right
so bishop g5 now knight c2 we said we're
bringing knight this knight on c2 so
there's no reason to uh
delay this and now jeffrey xiong goes
for rook b8
very interesting move this is all theory
of course black
in many occasions want to create
contemplate
with both a5 and b4 on the queen side
right
and here the main move by far
is a4 and this is where wesley saw
surprises his opponent with
enough bit variation a3 more
calm more humble move than a4 well a4
we reach this kind of positions b takes
a4 and i think
white's idea is just to play night
before and after knight b4 you can take
with the pawn
or the knight and of course there are
tons of games and this being
heavily studied by the best chess
players in the world
okay uh one question from patrick okay
one's a
remark i still don't see why not knight
takes e7
you can bring the other knight back to
d5 that's a very good question
that's a very good question after bishop
b7 knight tx e7 is not a very good move
you are not in trying to control d5
because now black takes with the knight
and then black has full control on the
d5 square and probably
is even gonna play d5 at some point
e4 is also under attack so this is why
you don't take on e7 you take an f6 you
eliminate pieces that control d5 that
was a very good remark
and it's very important to note this so
bishop b7 takes takes c3 bishop g5
knight c2 rook b8 and a3
now black goes shark castle
what do you think about this move h4
this is
not gonna tell you what i was going to
tell you what do you think about this
move h4
do you think it's just a blunder in this
position can i take this pawn on h4
[Music]
will you watch the queen's gambit on
netflix i mean i just saw like uh
every apples every ap episode sorry but
the last one
i just need the last one to finish i've
been enjoying a lot this uh this series
how about you guys
i think it actually
reflects is like the real chess
atmosphere in chess tournaments yeah
and also this bohemian lifestyle of
chess players
you know like traveling all our lives
you know staying in hotels
like uh kind of a messy life but also
the positions are extremely great i mean
they did a great job you don't see
this typical mistakes that you normally
see in chess movies right like
where h1 is black right for example
i saw some people criticizing this this
series but i i found it
pretty nice actually
well you can take on h4 that's right
because of queen h5 and suddenly this h
file is open
on h7 is under attack so basically this
just wins for white so
h4 is a very typical move in this kind
of positions and this is what wesley saw
played
so that's why jefferson decided to keep
this bishop on
86 and now how do we continue
you wanna play extremely aggressively
like wesley saw then
you should play what
how to win a winning position please
suggest me something i never can win
after getting a huge advantage
well you know this is training like
hours hours
hours of training and playing it's like
any other feel
any other subject g4 that's great guys
you're so strong today g4 the main
thread is just to go g5 and then trap
the bishop so here
there are three moves we can think of
the first one is g6
the second is f6 and the third one is
what is the third
the third move here to take in account
don't tell me g5 yeah don't tell me g5
g5 is just a terrible move yeah bishop
f4
this is a very typical theme because now
in many positions you want to take on f4
that bishop
but then the e file is going to get open
for example some bishop on b7 will be
putting pressure
on the e4 pawn right so that's why
these three moves are all possibilities
here in this position f6 was very
interesting i think
g6 i don't like it because after g5
bishop g7 let's say
something like knight c to e3 now
black's position is very
restricted and now after f5 which is the
only
reaction that you have in this position
i mean you have
different options but i like just taking
on f5 and then playing something like
bishop
h3 putting pressure on f5 and whenever
we reach these kind of positions where
we manage to exchange the light square
bishops
this is just very good for this is a
what we dream when we play the
against the especially yeah we have full
control on the light squares we have
an f6 square to jump with our knight and
then our kin is still extremely safe we
can even go long castles
in this kind of positions and then we
got these two against one
in the key inside right
i think actually gary kasparov was
giving advice right to this
netflix series at least that is what i
heard
from somebody but i know hundred percent
sure
okay guys so now g6 is not very good
move
instead bishop f4 by jefferson a very
common move
in in this positions and now how do we
continue we want to punish black for
having this bishop here in f4
so let's try to increase the pressure
against this this bishop on f4 how do we
achieve this g5 well the g5 is a very
aggressive move and i guess you know
black can continue with something like
bishop e6
and then or even moves like knight a5
knight a5 intend to go bishop b7
yeah g5 is very reasonable but queen f3
probably is just uh threatening just to
take upon immediately
yeah because now the bishop hasn't got a
room and then queen
of three i mean looks extremely natural
to me right
the last final match against borgov in
the queen's gambit is based off a real
game i mean i
i'm still not in the last episode so
let's not make any spoilers here for the
people
so would be nice yet to analyze
one of those games in the channel as
well
so bad harmon against vorgov okay so
white's idea is to take the bishop on f4
and basically black cannot do anything
so
black has to create some contemplate
against these ideas well i'm not so sure
if
white is straightening to win upon
immediately because after knight takes
f4 there's always the idea of queen f6
so there are many interesting moves in
this position
i think i was considering when i was
analyzing this game over the board i was
considering rook e8
to increase pressure on the e file
whenever black white captures on f4
um rookie 8 was one move that i was
considering also
a a5 right because after
a5 knight takes f4 it takes f4
quintex f4 b4 i mean
white is a full pawn up but black is
fully developed
right in this position and then we're
aiming to open the b5
the rook is perfectly placed on the on
b8 aiming to go to b2 in different
positions
and then we got the e5 square for the
knight where we put pressure on g for as
well
so i would say that there is nice
compensation for the sacrifice pawn
in this position right and
i got matter already did analysis on the
final game i can imagine yeah
okay so yeah a5 was definitely very
interesting
and what else can we play here bishop e6
in the game jeffrey sean went for bishop
b7 which makes
a lot of sense to me because now you
know after knight takes f4 which
didn't happen in the game he can still
play queen f6 right the queen on f3 is
actually unprotected and then we're
gonna get this bomb back
so this is why wesley saw didn't take on
f4 but
instead he went for g5 a move
that the engines punish
very hard let's see if you guys are able
to see why
g5 is you know dubious according to the
engines
it's actually very difficult to spot
this
and uh it's not a very common move for
black in this position
so i'm gonna tell you the move that
jefferson did so you don't think about
this move anymore
it's rook e8 which makes sense again
now in inviting white to take on f4 and
then therefore
opening the e files of the rook on here
this perfectly placed yeah
i don't you are so strong today what did
you eat some chocolate cookies or
some sugar exactly that's the move
knight a5 very strong move
of course black is threatening to take
on d5
and if black is sorry white takes on f4
then we just take on f4 queen takes f4
and now what do we play here
rookie 8 well rookie 8 it's
interesting but i guess i can just play
f3
f3 i consolidate the position and you go
d5 just go along
and then white is winning no not f3
forcing moves again forcing moves
captures
checks and threats that's that's right
team bishop takes e4
and white can take an e4 because of
rookie 8
so i mean and actually this is winning
because we are attacking the rook on h1
and then i don't see two there's a fork
and y cannot do anything right
so bishop e4 this is why knight a5 was
so strong in this position let's say for
example white goes
something like sure well i cannot even
go long castle in this position
just illegal yeah rook d1 stuff like
that
and then black can try to play f6 which
is another idea using the fact that the
rook is
in the same file as the queen and then g
takes bishop g5
and this looks again very very
interesting for black with
that f file open the king stuck in the
center
so probably black is a little bit better
in this position but instead
jeffrey went for rookie 8 as i was
telling you guys this is a very natural
move
to the human eye right because white is
threatening to take on f4
and then we open the e5 it's always so
easy to talk from outside right
we always talk with the deepest respect
to the players
i mean we go to the to the real
chessboard and then
we just blunder so many times nowadays
when we are just watching
a tournament we got the the bar right
the engine bar that is saying like oh
bishop h6 this is a great move
why didn't he play this but you know
chess is very tough you know so we
should always
uh have the deepest respects for all the
players
they are superstars and uh
well sorry guys for
all this [ __ ] so rookie 8 and now
wesley saw says you know what i'm going
to take this pawn on f4 knight takes if
f4 he takes f4 and here
wesley didn't go for queen f4
if white goes for queen four
now black to move and win
okay guys give me the winning move
i mean we have huge hints we got this
rook on e8 this bishop on b7
there has to be something related with
the e4 pawn
yeah so two more rounds to go in the u.s
championship
but wesley's hall has a full point lead
over
jefferson
knight a5 well with knight a5 again
i mean you're not forcing white to do
anything strange
just play f3 and then you go long castle
and white is better so
we gotta be very careful here that's
right knight b4
because with this move you're attacking
the knight on c2
at first glance could look very stupid
because i mean
looks like we're just blundering the the
knight but then there's rookie four
and then white loses the queen
so that's why knight b4 was winning this
position and wesley so
realized about that and he went for long
castle
which is a very good move because now
white is aiming to take the pawn on f4
if black goes something like knight e5
then just
queen f4 if black goes something like
knight f5
knight a5 sorry white can just play
bishop d3
or even a move like queen f4 this looks
better for
for white but bishop d3 just first we
protect the e4 and white is up a little
bit better
also this position looks very nice for
looks very nice for
for white i think white skin is very
safe
and we are playing bishop d3 next move
and then our structure is just much
better there is so much pressure
against d6
cool okay guys so let's go back
to the game so wesley saw went for long
castle
and here jefferson managed to create
fantastic contemplate we said like
knight a5 is not working knight e5 is
not working so what should we play with
the black pieces
do you have any ideas
yeah that's that's knight hands
that's a very nice suggestion you are
playing like jeffy sean
d5 this is just too much again
i think we can even take on f4 but or d5
it takes d5 this just looks like
a pawn out for white yeah so next move
is
probably even bishop g2 covering d5 you
go knight e7 bishop g2
and then you cannot even take back on d5
so
this is just a losing move right so b4
this is the idea
now let's try to understand all this
craziness right because
i mean this b4 could look very stupid
for
all of us right the idea is that after
atx b4
now black plays knight takes before
fantastic idea
from jefferson using again
these tactics the pawn on e4 ray rook on
h1
the queen on f3 and basically
white is forced to take on b4 right and
the most natural move is again knight
takes b4 because white doesn't want to
open
uh you know the c file so that's why
knight takes v4 was played
in this position and then bishop e4
from jefferson attacking the queen on f3
and the rook on h1 so here
we have two options the first the best
move was
queen a3 and after bishop h1
queen h1 white is better because the two
pieces
coordinate better than the rook right
and then the king is kind of safe in
this position
but probably after queen h3 black can
just play rook b4 and then this is
a real mess let's say if you take on b4
then you just play queen c8 something
like that
queen c3 and then bishop h1 and you know
this is still a complicated position
instead wesley saw decided to go for
queen
f4 and now jeffrey shawn had
an option where he could stand better
in this position how do we play with the
black pieces this is a
very tough move again would you take the
rook on h1 would you play a5 would you
take on b4
you have to remember that uh black is a
piece down right now so he has to get
some material back at some point
and well
if you take on h1 then f3
this humble move is very interesting and
also bishop c4
bishop c4 putting pressure on f7 and
also attacking the bishop on h1 so
f3 or bishop c4 both very interesting
for example
let's analyze a little bit f3
and then for example i don't know let's
say you play something like queen e6
then bishop c4
then again pressure on f7 and on the
bishop on h1
so that's why bishop hy is not the best
move in this position
uh jeffrey took on b4
but the best move here was queen a5
fantastic move just not grabbing any
material this is why
this move is so tough you know because i
mean black is a full piece down so
but the threat is quite nasty black
wants to go queen a1
in this in this position and then this
king has to go to dance south side in
the middle of the board then b2 is
under attack let's say here bishop d3
which is the only move now if the queen
he wants you can you can just go keen c2
i know this this game is pretty
complicated so we will try to go step by
step
pretty slow so we can understand
everything if you don't understand
something just
just ask me don't hesitate to ask yeah
please do this
don't go from this lecture without
understanding
something okay i'm just here for you
guys otherwise this makes no sense yeah
otherwise this is just a stupid spanish
guy talking in front of the screen
just alone feeling crazy you know what
am i doing with this life you know in
this pandemic talking nonsense
in front of a camera so queen e5 bishop
d3 and now
bishop h1 rook h1
is not possible because of queen a1
bishop b1 only moves the rook is
unprotected and now
this rule comes to finish the job rook
e2
and basically after knight d3 the other
rook is also attacking b2
and has to resign i mean rook h1 is not
the best move
here white can survive with another
interesting move
and it's some idea that we just saw two
minutes ago
can you guys find this move
so the king is kind of safe right now
the queen on f4 is protecting b4 which
is always interesting
yeah bishop c4 could be an option but i
think again
queen a1 now king c2 and then bishop b4
chair
troubles queen e4 just win the one
intermediate move and then rook takes e4
i mean we shouldn't
let this bishop go back to the game
that's the idea behind this move yeah s3
that's right anthony romero
mark anthony we got mark anthony here in
the chat so
bishop g2 this is the point and it looks
like this bishop is trapped so
when i was analyzing this game i was i
was thinking okay queen g3 and i just
grabbed the bishop but then
there is an important point now the
queen is not covering b4 and then
rook b4 is a big baboom city b4
and then queen a1 now the point is that
the c file is actually open
you go to c2 rook c8 winning you go to
d2 queen takes v2 is going to be
checkmate pretty soon
i know i know guys this game is too
complex
but this is what happens when the two
superstars play in the spashnikov
it's not as boring as uh the berlin
defense
this is the kind of chess that i really
like you know all pieces hanging you
know nobody knows what
really what is really going on
so queen a5 we were analyzing this game
bishop d3 bishop h1 and here we were
saying f3 bishop b2
and it looks like after bishop c4 or
even h5
white has songkong to play it still the
position is very complex
because black is an exchange hub for
sure is going to try to bring this
bishop back to the game
but of course the king the white skin is
safe
with this screen on f4 covering b4 and
then
i mean we have also some attacking
possibilities on the key inside right
with the palm march or even this bishop
targeting
h7 so
this is why queen e5 was a very
interesting move instead jeffrey went
for
rook takes v4 and now
again this is another tough moment for
us what do we play here with the white
pieces crazy position right
yeah exactly i mean why can't
white skin is safe like more or less
yeah
in those kind of positions that i was
explaining you guys i mean i was just
one move to go king b1 that's what i
meant yeah
and then the king on b1 is actually
pretty safe yeah
so rook takes d6 in this position or or
what
there's only one good move for wyatt
here let's try to
to understand what happens after rook d6
which is a losing move
crazy here black plays queen b8
attacking b2 you cannot go rook d2 back
because the queen on f4 is hanging
and then if you take on b4 then queen c7
the king is forced to go to d2 queen c2
and then no matter where the king goes
let's say kini 3 bishop h1 with the
check and then this is gonna be
check made very soon now the king is
forced to go to d4 and then
quintex b2 and then this is just
completely winning for black
so no rook d6 loses
so c takes b4 ctxv4 is also losing
because of the same idea queen c7 the
king is forced to go to d2 this bishop
is doing a fantastic job
just covering this dialogue so queen c7
the skin d2 and then queen c2 check
again the king has to go to the e file
which is completely opened
and yes bishop well this is even mate
yeah bishop f3 then the next move queen
takes d1 with a checkmate
oh no no c takes before no
rook d6
then what do we play
rook g1 rook g1 let's analyze rook g1
rook t1
boom kidney five
next move queen a1
next move you sign under the zero
rook three you want to play rook a3
queen a5 boom same idea
bye bye sayonara baby it was a pleasure
to meet you
but i think you are not my perfect match
so queen takes e6 trying to trade queens
boom
what do we play here
this is interesting windy six but i
think it's completely losing too
i think the move here could be is this
working rookie form
d4 rookie four works because now after
queen d8
we just give this intimate check with
rookie
rookie one king two and now rook d8
followed by rook takes e1
so queen d6 rookie for
winning beautiful
so no yeah that's right minnie
that's right nene bishop d3
i mean we realized that this diagonal
was
i mean was our biggest problem right
this bishop on e4 the king wants to go
to b1
so this is what wesley saw played in
this position bishop d3
and now black took on h1
bishop takes h1 and now queen takes b4
and then we reach this position
but still it's extremely complicated
white structure is a little bit better
so every end game
black would be suffering right so here
was this all
sorry jefferson went for bishop f3
attacking the rook and now
rook d2 he's not scared of rookie one
because i can just go to c2 and the king
looks more or less safe on c2 there are
no possible checks right
why are you ignoring bishop d3 because
first of all i wanted to check the rest
of lines yeah
yeah i mean the
i have opposite feelings in this
position because the structure is much
better for white
but white skin is a little bit more
shaky than black skin right so
this is why the engine says this
position is around equal
it's a pretty unbalanced position and
basically everything can happen
so mr jefferson went for d5 here
natural move normal pressure d6
and now well the other option was to go
rookie 1
king c2 and something like g6
and this was the favorite variation from
the engine
but okay he went d5 and now wesley saw
said you know what i just don't care
just gonna grab this pawn on a6
and then you have to justify that d5
give him one free pawn so jeffrey went
for h6 finally er
getting some fresh air for the kin the
h7 square so no more background problems
and here wesley saw said again you know
what i'm gonna
take this pawn on h6 and now jeffrey's
idea was to play
rook e4 attacking the queen
also attacking h4 so probably he is
getting some material back
really soon and now queen c4 from wesley
saw which makes a lot of sense
and here jeffrey makes a slight
inaccuracy in this position he took on
h4 which
makes a lot of sense the best variation
for black here was rookie one
king c2 and queen takes h4
and now black has so many nasty threats
for example
if you take on g7 which could look
natural to you because you have 13
actually made on f8 this queen a4
and now it's a white the one who loses
in this position
because after b3 you got bishop e4
followed by
queen a2 or queen a1 in case of kim b2
and white resigns
so after queen h4 probably
bla white can play b4 or even queen d4
and the position is still extremely
crazy after q6
basically anything can happen in this
kind of position
but geoffrey took on h4 and now
wesley saw decide to exchange queens so
his skin is now
safe and after quincy a bishop c8
rook h6 this in game is a little bit
better for white
why because we have this pawn on the b
file which is passed
and okay black has two versus one on the
key inside but still
he still has to create like a passport
with he has to
push the two pawns he wants to create
some troubles on the key inside he needs
a lot of moves
meanwhile we're gonna just push the b
pawn and then this skin is very close to
those pawns that's why this skin can
help
the people to succeed right
so white is the only one with a passer
currently black has to earn his
that's that's right patrick so what
is a bit better and let's see how the
game continues
bishop b7 from wesley saw attacking d5
and rook h5
protecting d5 finally run like a usain
bolt
b4 kin f8 of course black has to bring
this skin
to try to stop this guy king b2
now rook f5 from jefferson
he wants to push g5 but of course if he
does it right now then d5
d5 is under attack right so g5 then
bishop takes d5 just winning the game
this is why
rook f5 is played so he wants to protect
t5 and then
be able to push his pawns
so kim b3 from wesley so king e7
and king a4 finally black starts
his pawn march on the key inside and
then this is like a horse race right
everybody trying to promote in his flank
and here you're not gonna believe the
move that the engine says you know
i mean you wouldn't guess it like in in
30 years you know give me your candidate
moves guys
it's it's crazy we'll try to explain
the subtleties of this move but i mean i
struggled
a lot i was trying to to understand the
move and then
it took me like five minutes you know
so what do we play here with the white
pieces
you wanted to go c4 at some point you
wanted to go c4 here yeah
okay c4 c4 then rook
h1 c2 bishop four let's say
king goes somewhere i mean you cannot go
to c3 because there's d4
you have to go to c to b3 and then d
takes e4 so basically c4
is losing it's so hard yes
so we're in this position guys
a8 is the ng move
bishop a8 is the engine move it's crazy
it's just crazy now for example if black
goes g4 then we just go
b5 and then black goes rook f4 king a5
and then
the bishop is on the a file and not on
the b file so this pawn is faster
because now in the game white played
b5 straight away rook f4
king a5 now king d6
so the bishop is kind of annoying this
move so the engine is saying you know
what i prefer to have this bishop on a8
and then
that pawn on g4 this favors white
okay as i told you a very tough move to
see
now according to the engine black has a
lot of options let's see what happens so
b6
rook c4 targeting c3 and rook
d3 protecting carlitos
so rook c5 check king b4 rook c4
of course jeffrey is happy with the draw
right now king b3
now wesley goes for the win rook f4
protecting the bishop on f3 and now
c4
c4 putting pressure on d5
right now white wants to take this guy
on d5 and now black goes for
king c5 because now if black takes it
sorry white takes on d5 then
bishop takes d5 rook takes d5 king b6
and then this is a dead draw
you're gonna take on g5 and then black
is taking on f2
so after king c5 we took on d5
and then black went for rook b4
check king c3 and now
it's your turn what would you play here
with the black pieces
i mean white thread is pretty obvious
you want to go g6 and d7 and then just
promote so how do we stop this
we can't argue with the engine that's
right
not these days we could argue with the
engine like 15 years ago i remember when
i used to use
fritz number five in my analysis
and then you know i was facing pacquiao
spanish number one in the spanish
national championship like four or five
years ago
and then i was working as an engineer so
i didn't have the time to really
like train and analyze and stuff like
that so
so i was preparing with some analyses
that i had from
like 2005 or something and
you know paco i mean paco entered in my
analysis so i was so happy i i
i i have him he's in my preparation
but then i just look at the position i
said it's just completely rubbish you
know i mean i'm just completely lost i
was just following my preparation
and then of course i just go check with
stockfish and stockfish is just
like saying like all these lines from
fritz number five are completely rubbish
so you know this happens
we could argue with the engines like
some years ago or not anymore
every app in your cell phone bits micros
can beat magnus causing easily
so here rook takes v6 team morgan is
saying probably the most natural move
which
it's not the best one the best move here
was to play
bishop e2 for example
and now some crazy lines arise for
example d6
bishop takes d3 d7
rook d4 bishop d5
rook takes d5 b7 king c6 and king 67 and
the engine says this is around equal
okay crazy right and of course
uh i mean this was not
so easy to see so rook six what's
that of that uh jeffrey
sean plays and now
black is in trouble
how
so what do we play now guys
yeah d6 very good
because now if black takes the bishop on
b7 d7 just wins
basically black is forced to take the
bishop on b7 and sacrifice the exchange
so this is what geoffrey did rook b7 d7
there's no way to
stop the d-pawn so basically black has
to take a d7
and now rook takes c7 and then we reach
this end game where
black has some options but now you gotta
decide between
bishop d5 and f5 what do you play
you're gonna project f f7 right also f6
is is an option but let's just
first think in those two moves f5 and
bishop d5
f5 tim's voting for f5
trusting in facundo who solves all the
problems usually
f5 g4 you guys wanna
use the pawn march create a pass or two
i mean one consideration to be taking an
account in this position
if black manages to exchange these two
pawns it's a dead draw you guys know
that bishop vs rook is a draw
you just have to go to this corner and
then move the bishop
to g8 from from h7 to g8 yeah
this is the best defensive technique
but this is not so trivial
and the best move here to resist
is bishop d5 it's not that easy now you
want to play bishop e6
if the root goes away you bring the kin
closer to the points and then i mean
it's gonna be tough for white to
to proceed but in the game black went
for f5 which is
a losing mistake in this position
because now black just goes
king d3 and then bishop b4 check
king e3 g4
now the king is completely cut this
would be a different story if the king
is on e6
because you're protecting f5 but now
white's plan is very simple
what's the plan to win the game guys do
you see it
oh we got 400 people here in youtube
this is quite nice
so what's the plan to to win in this
position
just try to use that the kin is
completely far away from the pawns
so usually when the king is so far away
one nice idea is just to try to exchange
sorry to sacrifice the exchange on f5
that's right the king is too far away so
key in f4 i mean don't start with droog
f7
because now king d5 black hint
arrives to e6 and protect the probably
it's also winning but there's no need
for this we start with king f4
now black has to lose a tempo with king
c6 and now
rook f5 rook f7 sorry followed by rook
f5
king d6 takes f5 bishop takes f5
king takes f5 and now let's say king is
7
king g4 kin f6 and then
you play f3 here no right f3 is a draw
don't go at 3 guys s3 king g6 skinner
four king of sixes
yeah but you can go here key in a four
this is a winning move don't go f4
either f4 this is a dead draw
the idea is just to go for those who are
beginning with chess just
to win the so-called opposition yeah now
black has to move let's say to e6 and
then we just go
king g5 and then this is
a winning end game okay so
after nine rounds wesley saw is the sole
leader
of the tournament with eight out of nine
points after this fantastic big
victory against uh young
super talented player jeffrey sean don't
miss
the rest of the action today remember
you can follow
the games with commentary from the
saint louis chess club with yasir
sarawan maurice ashley
and jennifer shahabee it's been a
pleasure as usual guys i hope you
learned something and hope you had
some fun and just see you in in the next
video it's been a pleasure just take
care
and stay healthy bye bye guys